Naming Your Baby.
Honey, I've finally decided what to name our daughter!
I'm so excited to tell you.
I mean, I've been thinking about it all day!
So, are you ready? Here it is.
Our daughter is going to be called... Drum roll please.
Crystal! Yeah!
You know, after my Mom.
Whoa, Whoa, get a hold of yourself!
So what you're saying is, you named our daughter after your Mom?
I thought we agreed to name her after somebody on my side!
Okay, you should sit down and take a deep breath.
Just need to relax a bit.
So, honey, I'm afraid you've forgotten what our last name is.
For your information, it's Glass!
You want our daughter's name to be Crystal Glass?
She's going to be embarrassed about her name all her life!
What if she can't make any friends at school?
What if she becomes an outcast or something?
Okay, I need to take it easy.
Another deep breath.
Okay. So, what's her middle name going to be?
Can I have a say in that department?